Jon Snow is a fantasy hero – he
goes on adventures, falls in love,
and fights to save the realm. As a bastard,
Jon feels rejected, so he searches for family
and identity. And he struggles to do the
right thing in a morally complicated world.
The first three seasons of the Game of Thrones
TV show are a pretty close adaptation of the
books. But in the later seasons, TV Jon
is a very different character to book Jon.
TV Jon is a badass warrior who fights lots of
bad guys. He’s described as “brave” but “Stupid”,
cause he takes dumb risks. He’s not good at
politics because he’s so stubbornly honest. Actor
Kit Harington says “Jon is not able to lie”. TV
Jon only wants to do the right thing. He doesn’t
want to be a king – he says “I never wanted it”.
But in the books, Jon is different. Book Jon
is not a great warrior – he’s more of a smart
politician. Book Jon’s not always honest – he
lies and has secret plans. And he doesn’t just
wanna do the right thing. He’s also tempted by
his desires for honour, revenge, love, and home.
When he gets the chance to rule Winterfell,
he wants it. He thinks “I have always wanted it”.
Author George Martin writes about “the human
heart in conflict with itself”. Book Jon
is defined by internal conflict between
his desires and his duty, forcing him to make
tough choices. He constantly faces moral dilemmas
that question what it means to be a hero.
But in the later seasons of the TV show,
Jon often has no internal conflict. When
he just wants to do the right thing,
his choices have no moral or emotional cost.
And in the show, Jon’s big plot twists go
nowhere. Like, Jon dies then comes back to life
– but death doesn’t much change him, and his
resurrection is barely mentioned again. Jon finds
out he’s a Targaryen, heir to the throne – but Jon
doesn’t want the throne, or to be a Targaryen,
so this also doesn’t change him. Jon is set up
as the prophesied hero who’ll defeat the white
walkers, but in the end, Jon just shouts a dragon
while his sister saves the world. After seasons of
buildup, these twists and reveals feel pointless.
In the books, Jon’s resurrection will transform
him. His Targaryen blood has power. Jon is
deeply connected with prophecy and magic that
will change the world of ice and fire. Jon’s
moral and emotional struggles explore the series’
central themes of power, family and heroism. And
when Jon collides with Daenerys and Tyrion in the
final books – George Martin says it’ll be a very
different ending to the show. So who is the real
Jon Snow in the books, and how will his story end?
Jon Snow grew up at Winterfell with Lord Eddard
Stark, Lady Catelyn, and their children Robb,
Sansa, Arya, Bran, and Rickon. But Jon is
different to the other kids because he’s a
bastard – Jon is not Catelyn’s son, he’s the
son of some other woman. And Ned won’t tell
anyone who Jon’s mother is. Some say she was Lady
Ashara Dayne, others say she was a commoner. The
truth is probably that Jon is really the son of
Ned’s sister, Lyanna Stark, with Prince Rhaegar
Targaryen. Ned promised to protect Jon, so he
pretends to be Jon’s father. That’s what was
revealed in the TV show anyway, and there are
lots of hints that this is true in the books as
well. If Jon is Prince Rhaegar’s son, then Jon
is arguably the rightful King of Westeros. But
everyone thinks he’s Ned’s bastard, born outside
marriage – so Jon has the bastard name Snow,
not the trueborn family name Stark. Bastards have
lower social status in Westeros, and are widely
distrusted. So Jon faces prejudice and exclusion.
Catelyn feels hurt that Ned cheated on her,
and raised his bastard in their home. So
Cat never accepts Jon – she’s cold to him,
sometimes cruel, making Jon feel that he’s not
part of the family. This is partly for political
reasons – Catelyn wants to make sure that her
son Robb inherits Winterfell, and she worries
that Jon could be a political rival – so Catelyn
makes it clear that Jon is not a true Stark.
Jon even looks different to the Starks. In the
books, Robb Sansa Bran and Rickon have auburn
hair and blue eyes like their mother Catelyn.
But Jon has dark brown hair, and dark grey eyes,
like Ned. So Jon is the black sheep, who doesn’t
fit in. The only kid who looks like Jon is Arya,
and she’s also a misfit cause she’s a rebellious
tomboy. So Jon and Arya are close – Jon musses her
hair and calls her “little sister”. Robb is Jon’s
“best friend” and rival. Jon is kind to Bran and
to young Rickon. Though Sansa is distant with
Jon – she calls him half-brother, not brother.
So Jon loves the Starks, but because he’s the
bastard, feels he’s not part of the family.
In Book 1, Jon is a fourteen year old boy.
He’s quiet, brooding, sometimes “sullen”,
and hot-headed. But he’s empathetic and
open-minded – willing to listen, learn, and grow.
In Chapter 1, the Starks find five direwolf
pups. Direwolves are mystical creatures,
and the symbol of House Stark. Bran wants to
keep the pups, so Jon convinces Ned that the
five pups should belong to the five Stark kids.
Jon excludes himself, says he doesn’t get a wolf,
cause he’s a bastard – Jon sacrifices his
own happiness out of kindness for Bran.
But then, Jon hears a noise that no one else
can hear, so he finds one more direwolf,
apart from the others. It’s an albino with white
fur and red eyes, who he names Ghost. So Ghost
and Jon are both “different” and “apart”
from their families. Ghost’s white fur and
red eyes could be a hint of Jon’s real father
Rhaegar, because Rhaegar also had pale hair,
and wore Targaryen red. But it's strange how
Jon finds Ghost. Cause Jon hears a “noise”,
but we learn that Ghost is always silent, Ghost
never makes a sound, so what noise did Jon hear?
Maybe Jon was influenced by Bloodraven.
Bloodraven, or the three-eyed crow,
was once a Targaryen bastard politician. Now he’s
a greenseer, a sorcerer with the magic of the old
gods and the weirwood trees – Bloodraven teaches
Bran magic later on. And throughout the books,
Bloodraven manipulates events from afar, by giving
people dreams, and by controlling animals with
skinchanger or warg magic. Ghost is connected to
this magic – Ghost’s white fur and red eyes look
like the white and red weirwood trees – Jon
thinks that Ghost “belongs to the old gods”
Bloodraven also has white hair and a red eye.
So maybe Bloodraven used the magic of the old
gods to make Jon hear a noise, to make him find
Ghost. Bloodraven might even sent the direwolves’
mother south in the first place. Cause there
are hints that Bloodraven has plans for Jon,
wants to use him to fulfil prophecies to defeat
the white walkers. So Ghost not only symbolises
how Jon is different to his siblings, but
also connects him to mysterious magic.
King Robert comes to Winterfell, but at the
feast, Catelyn seats Jon at the back of the hall,
separate from the family. Jon feels he has
no future at Winterfell. Robb will be the
next Stark lord, his siblings will marry great
houses and rule holdfasts. But as a bastard,
Jon has no inheritance, no home here. So he
tells his uncle Benjen that he wants to join
the Night’s Watch. The Watch is an ancient
brotherhood who guard the Wall in the north.
Jon sees the Watch as his path to honour
and adventure, a chance to prove his worth.
Benjen warns Jon that Watch men serve for
life. They swear to never marry or have kids,
and to “hold no lands” and “wear no crowns” –
Benjen says Jon doesn’t understand the “cost”
of that oath. Some fans think that Benjen knows
that Jon is the son of Prince Rhaegar, and that if
Jon swears the Watch oath, he’d be giving up his
claim to the Throne. Cause Benjen was at Harrenhal
when Rhaegar and Lyanna’s relationship
likely began. Benjen’s grief and guilt
over Lyanna’s death might be why Benjen joined
the Night’s Watch – but that’s just a theory.
Jon feels rejected – he can’t join the Night’s
Watch, he can’t be a Stark, so who is he?
Jon and Arya watch Prince Joffrey and Robb
training at swords. Jon and Arya both want
to join in the training, but Jon’s not allowed
cause he’s a bastard, and Arya’s not allowed
cause she’s a girl. Jon says “Nothing is
fair”. This world discriminates by social
class and gender – it’s unfair that Joffrey
gets more power and privilege, just cause he’s
a prince and Jon’s a bastard. Which is ironic,
because Joffrey is actually Jaime’s bastard,
while Jon is secretly a prince. But the point
is that Jon experiences injustice and prejudice,
and that drives him to make justice later on.
Ned is going south, and Catelyn wants Jon gone.
So Ned agrees to send Jon to the Night’s
Watch – though Ned’s voice is “troubled”.
This chapter is from Catelyn’s point of view,
so we don’t get to see Ned’s thoughts here.
If Ned promised to protect Jon… why send
Jon to the Wall? Maybe Ned thinks that Jon
will be safer if he swears the Watch oath
to wear no crowns – cause then Jon can’t
be used in any dangerous political plots. Aemon
Targaryen joined the Watch for similar reasons.
So Jon is leaving Winterfell. He says goodbye
to Bran. And Catelyn is cruel to Jon – she says
she wishes Jon was in a coma instead of Bran. But
Jon tells Robb that Cat was kind to him, so that
Robb doesn’t feel bad – again, Jon sacrifices
his own feelings for the happiness of others.
Jon says goodbye to Arya, and gives her a sword
called Needle. He tells Arya to learn to fight,
in defiance of society’s sexist rules. And
for the rest of the books, Jon and Arya
think about each other often, hoping to reunite.
The TV show adds a scene where Ned says goodbye.
Jon asks about his mother, and Ned promises he’ll
tell Jon the next time they meet. Evoking Ned’s
promise to Lyanna. But tragically, Jon and
Ned never see each other again. In the books,
Jon dreams that his mother was beautiful and
kind. He also knows she may have been a whore.
He worries that Ned did something shameful
with his mother – why else would Ned be so
secretive? Jon is haunted by this painful mystery.
Jon rides north with Benjen and Tyrion Lannister.
And they’re joined by more recruits for the Watch.
Jon is upset to learn the recruits are criminals,
forced to join the Watch as a punishment. Jon
had thought the Watch was a noble brotherhood of
heroes – but Tyrion says it’s a dumping ground
for outcasts. Robb will inherit Winterfell,
while Jon is abandoned with the rejects.
At first, Jon gets angry at Tyrion – Ghost attacks
Tyrion – Jon has several emotional tantrums in the
books – like other Targaryens, Jon has a temper.
But then Jon cools down, and accepts that Tyrion
is right. His life will be hard, it’s not what he
hoped for. But growing up, becoming an adult,
means making the best of an imperfect world.
Tyrion tells Jon to be proud of his
bastard identity – to use it as a
strength. And Jon asks Tyrion to help Bran.
The bastard and the dwarf form an unlikely
friendship, which could be
important in later books.
Jon starts his new life at Castle Black, and
it sucks. Jon wants adventure beyond the Wall,
but he’s put into training, under the cruel
Alliser Thorne – Alliser calls Jon “Lord Snow”,
as a mocking nickname. Jon easily beats
the other recruits at sword practice,
cause Jon’s had proper training – so the boys
hate Jon. Jon is cold and alone on the Wall,
feeling sorry for himself, until the smith
Donal Noye gives Jon advice. He says Jon is
not the victim here – Jon may think his
life sucks, but Jon grew up in a castle,
the son of a great lord. Most Watch recruits
are peasants who’ve suffered way more than Jon
has. When Jon beats the other boys, he’s being a
privileged arrogant bully. Jon listens to Donal,
and starts to show empathy. He makes friends
with Grenn and Pyp, and he teaches the recruits
to fight better. Though Alliser gets angry at
Jon for undermining his authority. When Jon
stands up to Alliser, he makes a bitter, lasting
enemy. It’s kinda ironic that Alliser hates Jon,
’cause in Robert’s Rebellion, Alliser fought for
the Targaryens – and Jon is secretly a Targaryen.
Samwell Tarly arrives. Sam is fat, and scared, and
useless at fighting, so Alliser has Sam beaten.
Jon has sympathy for misfits, like Tyrion and Arya
and himself, so Jon protects Sam. Using persuasion
and threats, Jon convinces all the recruits to
not hurt Sam. So Jon becomes a leader, someone who
brings people together to protect the vulnerable.
Jon is frustrated by Sam’s weakness. But he
listens and tries to understand Sam. Jon looks
past Sam’s flaws, and sees his strengths – that
Sam is smart and good with books. So Jon asks for
Sam to become Maester Aemon’s steward, arguing
that the world needs the unique talents of all
different people. Jon makes change to empower the
vulnerable. The TV show doesn’t include this bit.
TV Jon is not as interested in change and justice,
which makes him a more passive character. Book
Jon has political values and a vision for change,
which gives him a reason to want power.
Jon graduates to become a full brother of
the Watch. Jon wants to be a ranger, to patrol
beyond the Wall. But he’s made a steward,
a servant for Commander Jeor Mormont. At first,
Jon is angry, says he’s too good to be a mere
steward. But Sam says Jeor will teach Jon to lead,
will groom him for command. So again Jon listens,
puts aside his childish arrogance,
and accepts his new responsibilities.
Jon swears his Night’s Watch oath at a weirwood
tree, sacred to the old gods – he feels connected
to the gods of the Starks and the north. He
swears to take no wife, no lands, no children,
and no crowns, to be the sword in the dark, the
fire against the cold, the light of the dawn,
to guard the realms of men until his death.
The Watch is a motley brotherhood of outcasts
and underdogs. But it becomes Jon’s family.
He still loves the Starks, but he was never
one of them. The Night’s Watch are his brothers.
The boys celebrate their graduation with snowball
fights and childish horseplay – they’re
so innocent, unprepared for the dangers
to come. Alliser says that in winter, these
boys will die like flies. Childhood will end,
many will die. ’Cause “The cold winds
are rising”, and “winter is coming”.
Uncle Benjen is missing. He went beyond the Wall
with six men, and hasn’t come back. Ghost finds
two of Benjen’s men dead. Their bodies are pale,
with blue eyes – so Jon fears they were killed by
the Others, or white walkers, the legendary ice
demons from beyond the Wall. Thousands of years
ago, in the Long Night, the walkers attacked with
an army of the dead. And now they are returning.
In the night, Ghost leads Jon to find that one
of the corpses has risen from the dead – it’s
now a wight, a zombie controlled by the white
walkers. So Jon bravely fights the wight,
and kills it with fire. Jon’s hand gets burned
in the fire – cause in the books, Targaryens can
be burned, they’re not all fireproof. And
for the rest of the story Jon flexes his
scarred burned hand – a constant reminder of
the white walker threat. It seems this wight
was trying to kill Commander Jeor. Meanwhile,
the other corpse rises and kills the acting
First Ranger. So the white walkers are targeting
high-ranking officers to weaken the Night’s Watch.
It's interesting that Ghost leads Jon to the
wights. Maybe Bloodraven is influencing Ghost,
leading Jon to face the white walkers.
Jon saved Jeor’s life – he proved himself. So
Jeor gives Jon a sword called Longclaw. Longclaw
is a bastard sword – which means it’s bigger
than a normal one-handed sword. And Longclaw is
Valyrian steel, a super sharp blade from Valyria,
the ancient dragonlord empire – which subtly
connects Jon to his Valyrian Targaryen ancestors.
For centuries, Longclaw was held by Jeor’s
family House Mormont, passed down from
father to son. But Jeor’s son Jorah fled the
country. So when Jeor gives the sword to Jon,
he symbolically chooses Jon as his new son.
Jon has mixed feelings about this. Jon had once
dreamed that his father Ned would give him the
Stark family sword. Jon is loyal to Jeor – and Jon
is desperate for a father figure – but he doesn’t
want to replace Ned. He feels torn between the
Watch and the Starks – but he accepts the sword.
And Longclaw gets a new pommel shaped like Ghost.
In the south, Ned is imprisoned by King
Joffrey, and Robb marches south to save him. Jon
desperately wants to help the Starks – but he’s
sworn to stay on the Wall. So what should he do?
Maester Aemon says the reason why Watch
men swear to have no family is “So they
will not love”. Watch men should be focussed on
defending the realm, and if they have families,
that would divide their loyalties, and weaken the
Watch. Aemon says love is “the death of duty”,
so to do his duty, Jon must let
go of his love for the Starks.
Aemon has felt this pain himself, cause Aemon’s a
Targaryen – he’s the great-granduncle of Daenerys
and Rhaegar. And great-great-granduncle of
Jon Snow. When the Targaryens were overthrown
in Robert’s Rebellion, when his family was
slaughtered, Aemon kept his oath on the Wall.
So will Jon stay for his duty, or help the Starks
out of love? Jon wants to do the right thing,
but either choice feels like a betrayal. This is
Jon’s first moral dilemma – a choice where there
is no totally right answer, both options have a
cost. So Jon has to compromise, make sacrifices,
think hard about his values and morality. This
is what Jon’s story is all about – exploring
how to be a hero in a morally complex world.
Later, the Lannisters execute Ned. They kill
Jon’s only parent. So then Jon chooses love
– he rides south to help Robb. Jon knows the
punishment for leaving the Watch is death. So
Jon decides he’ll be a fugitive – “friendless,
and damned”. He only hopes to avenge his father
in battle – so that Jon can die like a true Stark.
Jon is as dramatic and naïve as Sansa, in Book
1 – fantasising of a glorious self-sacrifice.
Jon rides south, but his friends go after
him. They remind him of his duty to his
Watch brothers, and bring him back to the Wall.
Jeor tells Jon to grow up. There’s no point in
Jon getting himself killed by deserting. Jon
can’t bring Ned back to life, and Jon won’t
make a difference in Robb’s army. The war in
the south is not as important as the war in the
north – cause beyond the Wall, wildlings are
gathering, the walking dead are attacking the
Watch – they are the enemies that matter. Jeor
says Jon belongs on the Wall – because he has
the blood of the Starks, with the magic of the old
gods, and his direwolf. The Watch is his destiny.
Jon reflects that he has “no rights, no
name”, and now no parents. All he has is
his Watch duty. Jon is “troubled” by his loves
and loyalties, but decides he’ll keep his vows.
At the start of Book 1, Jon is an immature
boy, angry at the world for rejecting him. But
Jon listens to Tyrion, Donal, Aemon, and Jeor. He
extends his empathy to the outcasts of the Watch,
and becomes a leader who defends the weak.
A warrior who fights the dead. But being
a hero is complicated. Jon is torn between
his duty to the Watch and his love for the
Starks – can he fight for the greater
good and protect the people he loves?
In Book 2, the Watch rides north. Jeor leads
three hundred men beyond the Wall to find Benjen,
to face the white walkers and to find the
wildlings. Many wildling villages have recently
been abandoned, so Jeor wants to find out where
the wildlings went. They stop at a village called
Whitetree, which has an enormous “monstrous”
weirwood tree. The tree has a jagged mouth
full of human bones, like a sacrifice to the old
gods. The wildlings burn their dead so they don’t
rise again as wights. Above, the mystical
red comet burns, evoking ancient prophecy,
foretelling change and doom. Book 2 has a
growing sense of mystery and dark magic.
Jon once dreamed of adventure beyond the Wall.
But this adventure sucks. They ride through rain,
Jon’s back hurts, the food’s bad – it’s no fun.
He learns that real life is not like a fantasy
story. Life is harder, and more complicated –
sometimes good and evil are not as they seem.
The rangers stop at Craster’s Keep. Craster is a
wildling – and the son of a Night’s Watch man. And
Craster marries his own daughters, has children
of incest, and rules his daughter-wives with
violence and fear. Craster even sacrifices his
baby sons to the white walkers. So Craster is
an evil man. But the Night’s Watch treat him as
an ally – Craster gives them shelter and intel,
so the Watch gives Craster trade, and weapons.
This monster is a “friend” to the Watch.
One of Craster’s daughter-wives, Gilly, begs Jon
for help. She’s pregnant, and she wants Jon to
take her and her baby to safety. Jon wants to help
her, but the Watch won’t protect a wildling girl,
and won’t defy their friend Craster. So Jon feels
ashamed. He had thought that the Night’s Watch
were the good guys, but they won’t help this
innocent girl, and they befriend the monstrous
Craster. Ned taught Jon that it’s wrong to make
alliances with evil men. So Jon questions if the
Night’s Watch is doing the right thing. Jeor says
the Watch’s only purpose is to guard the realm,
not to do justice – that sometimes, you have
to tolerate evil for the greater good. So
Jon wonders if it’s right to compromise
your morals. If you protect the realm,
but tolerate evil, what are you saving?
At Craster’s Keep, there’s a bear skull
on display. And Jeor Mormont’s nickname is the
Old Bear. So the bear skull foreshadows Jeor’s
death at Craster’s Keep later on.
Jeor learns that the wildling king
Mance Rayder has gathered the wildlings in the
Frostfang mountains. That’s why those villages
were abandoned. So the rangers continue north
to the Fist of the First Men. The Fist is a hill
defended by walls built by the ancient First Men.
It’s a mysterious, powerful, prehistoric place,
like a… fantasy Stonehenge. Ghost acts weird
at the Fist, and he leads Jon to a hidden
package – it’s a bunch of dragonglass blades, and
an old horn, in a Night’s Watch cloak. Weapons
made of dragonglass can kill white walkers. And
this horn might be the Horn of Winter, a legendary
artifact with the power to destroy the Wall.
Someone must’ve put this here to help Jon and
the Watch fight the white walkers, and to keep the
Horn safe. Maybe it was put here by Uncle Benjen.
Or by Coldhands, the mysterious undead servant of
Bloodraven. In the TV show, Benjen is Coldhands,
but in the books Benjen and Coldhands might be
separate characters. It’s confusing. But either
way, Bloodraven could be behind this. Bloodraven
might’ve influenced Ghost to lead Jon here – that
would explain Ghost’s weird behaviour. In the
TV show, Sam randomly finds this package, but
in the books it’s Jon, guided by mystical forces.
Qhorin Halfhand arrives. Qhorin is a legendary
ranger – the wildings’ deadliest enemy. He’s
called the Halfhand because he lost some fingers
in battle with wildlings. Qhorin says Mance
plans to attack the realm, and to break the
Wall with magic – using the Horn of Winter.
So Qhorin leads a mission to investigate,
and he chooses Jon to come with him. Because
Qhorin notices that Jon has Ghost, and has the
blood of the Starks, connected to the old gods.
So Jon, Qhorin, and his men journey into the
mountains. It’s a harsh land, but Jon
sees beautiful waterfalls, wildflowers,
and ravines – turns out there is beauty in
adventure sometimes. They see wildlings ahead,
so Jon climbs a dangerous mountain trail and
kills a wildling called Orell. Orell is the
first person Jon has ever killed, not including
that zombie. And Orell is a skinchanger who’s
magically connected to his eagle, so when
Orell dies, Orell’s spirit lives on inside
his animal. For the rest of the book, Orell’s
eagle follows Jon, spying on him, wanting revenge.
Jon also faces a wildling named Ygritte. Jon had
been taught that wildlings are all nasty evil
murderers. But Ygritte is a girl with red hair –
she reminds him of Arya. Jon doesn’t want to kill
this girl. So Jon captures her, and they talk,
and she shows him a different perspective on the
world. Like, the Watch says wildlings are invaders
and thieves, but from Ygritte’s perspective,
the southerners stole the wildlings’ land.
Jon thinks he’s from “the north”, but from
Ygritte’s point of view, Jon is from the south,
and she’s from the north. Everything’s relative.
Good and evil can depend on your perspective.
Ygritte tells a story about a wildling called
Bael. Bael had a baby with a Stark girl,
and that baby became a Stark king. So
the Starks and the wildlings are related.
They’re family. So why are they enemies?
The story of Bael and the Stark girl also mirrors
the story of Rhaegar and Lyanna Stark – Bael took
a blue winter rose from Winterfell, and blue
winter roses were Lyanna’s favourite flower.
Bael and the Stark hid in the Winterfell crypts –
which is a hint that Jon will find out about his
parents in the crypts. Jon has recurring dreams of
the crypts, where he’s searching for his father,
and he knows he has to go down there.
Ygritte is a wilding warrior, an enemy of
the Watch. So Jon prepares to kill her. But then
he thinks of Ned. Ned said that when you execute
someone, you should look in their eyes, and hear
their words, to see if they really deserve to die.
When Jon looks in Ygritte’s eyes, he sees no evil.
So Jon follows Ned’s example of justice and mercy.
And he decides to let Ygritte go free.
In the TV show, it’s different – Ygritte
escapes from Jon, and he chases her, running and
jumping through the mountains. But in the book,
Jon chooses to spare Ygritte, he makes a moral
decision. He's learning that the world is more
complex than Watch good, and wildlings
bad. People are not just black-and-white.
That night, Jon has a crazy dream. He magically
connects with Ghost, and he sees a weirwood tree
with Bran’s face. Bran connects with Jon and Ghost
from afar through the magic of the old gods, and
he shows Jon a huge wildling army nearby. Then,
Ghost is attacked by Orell’s eagle. When Ghost
returns injured, it proves that Jon’s dream was
real. Qhorin says Jon is a warg, connected to his
wolf. He says magic is returning to the world –
“old powers are waking”, and “the trees have eyes
again”. In the TV show, Qhorin is not interested
in magic or Ghost. The show removes most of the
magic from Jon’s story. But in the books, Jon
is influenced by dreams, magic and prophecies,
leading him towards a mysterious destiny.
The Watch men retreat, but wildlings chase
them through the mountains. The men split
up until it’s just Jon and Qhorin left.
Since Qhorin is a famous ranger, he knows that
the wildlings will kill him. But the wildlings
might spare Jon. Qhorin tells Jon to join
the wildlings – to infiltrate the enemy and
find out their plans. Jon doesn’t want to be
a spy. He wanted to become an honourable hero,
not a sneaky traitor. But sometimes a hero has
to sacrifice their honour for the greater good.
When Jon and Qhorin are caught by the wildlings,
Qhorin pretends to be angry at Jon, and attacks
him, and lets Jon kill him. With the Halfhand
dead, the wildlings let Jon live. For now.
So in Book 2, Jon finally gets an adventure beyond
the Wall. But it’s not like expected. Turns out,
the Night’s Watch aren’t all good, cause they
work with Craster and don’t help Gilly. And
the wildlings aren’t all evil – some of them
are cute redheads. Jon has to kill one of his
sworn brothers, and join the enemy, making
him question his loyalties, his morality,
and his identity. He feels he’s lost his Stark
family, and now he’s lost his Watch brothers,
too. So who is he now? It also seems that
he’s a warg, magically connected to his wolf,
and to the old gods, so what is he now?
In Book 3, Jon is captive crow,
surrounded by thousands of wildlings.
He meets the wildling king Mance Rayder,
and asks to join their side. In the TV show,
this scene is tense – the wildlings are cold,
and threatening. In the books, it is tense, but
it’s also warm and colourful. Mance plays music
and sings. Tormund tells jokes. We meet Mance’s
pregnant wife, Dalla. And Dalla’s sister Val,
and her lover, all cooking and drinking together.
The wildlings aren’t just threatening, they’re a
family – and family is what Jon has always wanted.
The wildlings aren’t all nice – Rattleshirt
threatens to sew a weasel inside Jon’s belly.
The wildling chief Harma Dogshead kills a dog
each fortnight. And there’s Styr, the leader of a
wildling group called the Thenns. In the TV show,
Styr is a scary cannibal who threatens
to eat Olly’s mum. But in the books,
Styr is a more reasonable political leader. The
Thenns are the most technologically advanced and
socially organised wildling culture. They forge
bronze weapons, and have lords and laws. Which is
important later, when Jon tries to integrate the
Thenns into the realm. Wildlings aren’t all the
same – their cultures are unique and colourful.
In the TV show, Mance is a just a tough proud
wildling leader. But in the books, Mance
has layers. He’s more smart, charismatic,
and passionate, with a real philosophy to his
motivations. Mance was raised by the Night’s
Watch, but he left to join the wildlings.
Because Mance wants freedom, individuality,
pleasure. He joined the wildlings “for
a place where a kiss was not a crime”,
where “a man could wear any cloak he chose”.
The wildlings call themselves the free folk,
cause they don’t kneel to lords or kings.
They do sometimes follow kings like Mance,
but only by choice – they’re always free to
do what they want. Free folk are not divided
into highborn and lowborn, or trueborn and
bastards. And women have more equality,
with spearwives like Ygritte fighting alongside
men. The wildling life is dangerous, but Ygritte
says freedom and pleasure are worth the risk.
So compared to the Night’s Watch, those cold
lonely men with no freedom and no families, the
wildling life is way more fun. Free folk society
is more fair than the exploitative class system
of the south. Jon tells Mance that he wants to
join the wildlings because they treat bastards
equally, unlike southerners who discriminate
against bastards. Mance is suspicious of Jon, but
Jon’s knowledge of the Watch is useful – so Mance
lets him join them. Secretly, Jon’s still
loyal to the Watch. But he is tempted by
the wildlings’ freedom, equality, and warmth.
Suddenly, Jon is attacked by Orell’s eagle.
Orell’s spirit wants revenge for Jon killing him,
so the eagle tears up Jon’s face. So Jon is left
scarred and haunted by the ghost of the first
man he killed – his violence has consequences.
The wildlings go to the Fist, and
they learn that the Night’s Watch
were attacked here by white walkers. In this
battle, hundreds of Watch men were killed.
And then Commander Jeor is killed in a mutiny.
So with the Watch scattered, now’s a good time
for the wildlings to attack. Mance sends Styr
and Ygritte and Jon and a hundred wildlings to
climb the Wall and attack Castle Black. Mance
says if Jon is disloyal, cut out his heart.
Ygritte helps Jon be accepted by the wildlings.
She’s grateful that Jon spared her life. She
also has a big crush on Jon, and wants to
have sex with him. Jon is reluctant – cause
Watch men aren’t meant to have sex. And Jon
has always been determined to never father a
bastard. As a bastard, Jon suffered prejudice
all his life, so he doesn’t wanna get Ygritte
pregnant and bring another bastard into the
world. But Tormund reminds Jon that wildlings
don’t discriminate. They’re free to have sex and
have kids with whoever they want, without shame.
And Ygritte explains more of the wildling
philosophy. She says “The gods made the
earth for all men t’ share”, and that it’s
wrong for southern kings to rule over land
and people. She shows Jon that giants aren’t
monsters – they’re a unique culture, and it’s
tragic that they’re going extinct. Just as it’s
tragic that the wildlings are under threat,
they might go extinct. Ygritte says “You know
nothing, Jon Snow” – teaching him whole new
political and moral perspectives on the world.
So Jon feels conflicted, and confused,
and horny. Jon is a sixteen year old boy, and
this redhead is throwing herself at him. So Jon
has sex with Ygritte – he loses his virginity, and
breaks his oath. Breaks his oath in spirit, if not
technically. They have a particularly memorable
tryst in a cave, and Ygritte says she never wants
to leave. With Ygritte, Jon experiences love and
sex and freedom. He wants to be with her. But deep
down, Jon knows he’s not a wildling, he’s of the
Starks and the north, and he will have to leave
Ygritte to protect his home from her people. Like
Romeo and Juliet, Jon and Ygritte are star-crossed
lovers, on opposing sides, both doomed to die.
Jon and the wildlings climb the Wall. In the TV
show, this is dramatic – they all climb up
by hand, and Jon falls, and Ygritte falls,
and Jon saves her. But in the book, it’s only a
small team of climbing experts who climb by hand.
From the top of the Wall, they drop a rope ladder
so the others can climb up more easily. And they
start climbing from the top of a hill, where the
Wall is not as tall. George Martin really thought
about the most logical and realistic way to
climb a seven hundred foot magic ice wall.
South of the Wall, they find an old man, and Styr
tells Jon to kill him – to test Jon’s loyalty.
Jon looks in the man’s eyes, and he thinks of Ned
Stark. So Jon refuses to kill this innocent man.
With Ygritte, Jon refused to kill a wildling. Now
he refuses to kill a southerner – Jon rejects the
black-and-white morality of the Watch versus
wildlings, and protects people on both sides
of the Wall. Before Styr can cut out Jon’s heart,
Jon is saved by Bran. Because Bran and his mates
are hiding nearby, and Bran wargs his direwolf to
attack the wildlings. So once again, the magic of
the old gods guide Jon. Jon escapes the wildlings,
though Ygritte shoots him with an arrow.
The TV show adds more scenes that deepen the
drama between Jon and Ygritte. The actors Kit
Harington and Rose Leslie have great chemistry
– so good that they are now married with kids.
Jon returns to Castle Black. And in the
show, this is where Season 3 ends. The
first three seasons are pretty close to
the books – but from Season 4 onwards,
the show gets increasingly different to the books.
Season 4 adds a plotline where Jon goes back to
Craster’s Keep, to kill the mutineers who killed
Jeor. In the books, it’s Coldhands who kills these
mutineers – then he feeds their bodies to Bran.
But in the show, Jon fights the mutineers,
who are led by Karl Fookin Tanner – a cartoonishly
evil villain. The books are about Jon learning a
more complex moral perspective, fighting emotional
battles in his heart. But this show plotline…
it’s about good guys killing bad guys. Karl
does teach Jon a lesson about fighting dirty,
and the cost of honour. But most of this
plot is filler. The show starts to make
changes that miss the meaning of the books.
In the book, Jon gets back to Castle Black,
and he’s a mess. His leg is wounded, his
heart is broken from leaving Ygritte,
he finds out that Winterfell was burned
and Bran and Rickon are believed dead.
But Jon puts aside his pain, and focusses on
protecting others. The wildlings are coming,
and Castle Black is not ready. Officer Bowen Marsh
took most of their men off chasing wildling feint
attacks. So now there’s only forty men left to
defend Castle Black. Styr has a hundred wildlings,
south of the Wall. So it looks like they’re
doomed. But Jon and Donal make a plan.
Styr’s wildlings attack. And Jon
shoots at them with arrows. Jon
knows these wildlings. He travelled with
them, climbed the Wall with them. And now
he has to kill them. When Jon sees Ygritte,
he can’t bring himself to kill his lover.-
The Watch men retreat up the Wall,
and the wildlings chase them up the
stairs. So then Jon and Donal spring their
trap – they burn and collapse the stairs,
killing Styr and his wildlings. So in the TV
show, Jon has an epic sword fight with Styr.
But in the book, Jon uses a smart plan to win.
After the battle, Jon finds Ygritte, wounded. He
holds her in his arms, tells her she’ll be okay.
She says he knows nothing, and she dies. Ygritte
showed Jon freedom and love, and that’s what
makes it meaningful that Jon gives up his love
to defend the realm. Jon feels terrible guilt for
betraying Ygritte, and that pain never leaves him.
Styr is dead. But north of the Wall is
Mance’s army – tens of thousands of wildlings,
with cavalry, and chariots, and a hundred giants
riding a hundred mammoths. Some mammoths have
towers full of bowmen on their backs, like
the oliphaunts in Lord of the Rings. This is
the full strength of the free folk, “The fury
of the wild”, come to smash their way south.
Jon looks at the wildlings and thinks “There is
no place for you here. Go away”. This same line
is also in a dream Jon has about Winterfell –
the Stark statues tell Jon “There is no place
for you here. Go away”. It’s also similar
to when Catelyn tells Jon to “go away”,
“We don’t want you here”. So Jon’s rejection
from the Stark family is like how the wildlings
are rejected from the realm. The wildlings and
Jon are both outcasts, and he feels sympathy
for them. But he can’t let this army invade his
homeland. He’s conflicted. But he keeps his oath.
The Watch men shoot at the wildlings from atop
the Wall, while the wildlings try to break the
gate into the Wall’s tunnel. Which doesn’t make
much sense – cause the wildlings can’t hurt the
Watch men up on the Wall, and the thousands of
wildlings can’t all attack the gate at once,
so most of them just stand around getting
shot. Wildlings are not great at tactics.
But a giant named Mag the Mighty breaks
into the tunnel. And he’s stopped by
Donal Noye. The great giant and the humble smith
die together. With Donal dead, Jon takes command.
This battle continues for days. The Watch men
fix the gate. The wildlings build a ram. So
Jon drops barrels of gravel to smash
the ram. And the wildlings back off.
So again, this is different to the TV show. In
the show, Jon fights the wildlings with his sword
like a badass. But in the books, Jon stays out of
close combat. Jon is only sixteen in the books,
and he’s not a great warrior. So instead, Jon
uses smart ideas, like the barrels and the burning
stairs. He plans to improve the Wall’s defences
with hoardings and turnable trebuchets. Book Jon
is not just a fighter. He’s a smart leader.
So Jon holds the Wall. With just forty men,
against thousands of wildlings. Then Night’s Watch
reinforcements arrive – led by Alliser Thorne and
Janos Slynt. Janos was commander of the City
Watch in King’s Landing – after Janos betrayed
Ned Stark, he was sent to the Wall. Janos makes
friends with Alliser, who still hates Jon – so
together they accuse Jon of joining the wildlings,
and murdering Qhorin. They use Jon’s bastardy and
his old gods against him, using prejudice to make
Jon look bad. When they insult Ned, Jon gets angry
and attacks Alliser. So Janos and Alliser send
Jon on a suicide mission to kill Mance Rayder.
Jon knows this won’t work – he’s already betrayed
Mance, the wildlings will kill him, but he has
no choice. So Jon bravely faces death. Jon had
wanted to prove himself worthy and honourable,
Ned Stark’s true son. But even after all his
sacrifices, he’s still hated and rejected,
seen as a traitor by both wildlings and the Watch.
Being heroic does not get Jon the love he craves.
Jon goes to the wildlings. And Tormund is
friendly. They chat about Tormund’s family, and
toast to the memory of Donal, Mag, and Ygritte.
There are good people on both sides of this war
– so the conflict feels tragic and pointless.
Then Jon faces Mance. Mance wants to end the
fighting. He says his “people have bled enough”.
The white walkers have been attacking the
wildlings for years, driving them from their
land. So the wildlings need to get south of
the Wall to escape the dead. The wildlings aren’t
just invaders, they’re refugees. Though Jon knows
that some of the wildlings are brutal raiders,
so it’s not so easy to just let the wildlings in.
Mance says he has the Horn of Winter, and
threatens to use it to destroy the Wall.
Though this horn is probably a fake. Jon
considers sacrificing himself to break the
Horn. But at the last moment, the wildlings
are attacked – by Stannis Baratheon’s army.
The Night’s Watch sent letters to every king in
the realm, begging for help against the wildlings.
And the only one who shows up to protect the realm
is Stannis. Stannis’ knights quickly defeat the
disorganised wildlings. And Jon protects Mance’s
wife Dalla as she dies giving birth to a baby.
So Stannis saves the Night’s Watch. He wants
to defeat the white walkers and win the Iron
Throne. So he needs to take the north, which is
currently ruled by the Boltons. Stannis needs a
northern leader loyal to him. So Stannis offers
to legitimise Jon, to make him legally trueborn,
not a bastard. Jon Snow would become Jon Stark,
the Lord of Winterfell. This is what Jon has
always wanted – to be a true Stark, Ned’s heir.
To defy the rejection of Catelyn, and his envy of
Robb, and to claim Winterfell as his home. Stannis
also wants to marry Jon to Val, the sister-in-law
of King Mance, so that Jon and Val might form an
alliance between the north and the wildlings. Jon
is attracted to Val. She’s beautiful, capable, and
witty – she flirts with Jon, and Jon fantasises
about having children with her at Winterfell.
Jon wants this more than anything. But to rule
Winterfell, he’d have to leave the Night’s Watch,
desert his sworn brothers. And Stannis’ priestess
Melisandre wants Jon to burn the Winterfell
weirwood tree, and to worship her fire god
R’hllor. Jon can’t betray his father’s gods, the
gods of Ghost and of his dreams. So Jon is tempted
by Stannis’ offer. But the Watch needs Jon.
With Commander Jeor dead, the Watch holds an
election to choose a new leader. Janos Slynt
almost wins the vote. But Sam does some sneaky
political manipulation to help Jon win. Jon
doesn’t want to be Commander. And some Watch
men see Jon as a traitor, a bastard and a
warg. But others think Jon’s a good choice,
because he was Commander Jeor’s steward, and Ned
Stark’s son and Benjen’s nephew, he stopped the
wildlings. And Jon also gets support from a raven.
Cause Jeor Mormont had a talking pet raven. And
at the final vote, this raven reappears and
says “Snow, snow”, and lands on Jon’s shoulder
– like a sign that Jon should be the next
Commander. So Jon wins the vote and becomes
the 998th Lord Commander of the Night’s Watch.
It’s pretty weird that a talking raven helps
Jon win an election. This raven often seems
intelligent throughout the books, as though
it understands human language. Later, the raven
seems to give Jon a dream about fighting the dead
with a flaming sword and black ice armour,
and the raven says “King”, “Snow, Jon Snow”,
then wakes Jon with a “gnarled hand”. So some fans
think that this raven is magically controlled by
Bloodraven. We know that Bloodraven can magically
control animals, and he has used ravens to spy in
the past. So maybe Bloodraven uses this raven to
spy and influence the Watch. It looks like he’s
guiding Jon to lead the Watch to defeat the
white walkers, and perhaps to become a king.
The TV show removes the talking raven, and
removes Sam’s sneaky politicking – it takes
away the magic, and the morally murky politics,
and just has Jon win because he’s a cool guy.
But Jon becomes commander of the Watch
– the Wall is his, the night is dark,
and now he’s got Stannis to deal with.
In Book 3, Jon tastes freedom and love
with Ygritte – but he gives that up for his duty
to the realm. Stannis offers to make Jon the Stark
of Winterfell, his deepest desire. But again Jon
sacrifices his desires for the greater good. Jon
wants to do the right thing, but it’s hard to
know which choice is right. The wildlings show
him a whole different perspective on politics and
morality – good and evil are more complex than he
thought. And every choice Jon makes has a painful
cost. He’s lost the Starks, he’s lost Ygritte,
he’s lost friends in battle, leaving Jon wounded
and traumatised. He becomes more withdrawn,
sad, and isolated, as he struggles to do the
right thing in an impossibly complex world.
In the book, Commander Jon Snow walks a dangerous
political tightrope. Jon has to help Stannis,
or else Stannis will destroy him. But if he helps
Stannis too much, the Lannisters will destroy
them. Cersei actually plots to assassinate Jon in
the books, but she fails. Jon also needs to make
peace between the Night’s Watch and the wildlings
before the white walkers come and kill them all.
So Can Jon unite everyone to survive this winter?
In Book 5 and Season 5, Jon’s plotline becomes
very different in the books
compared to the TV show.
Aemon says “Kill the boy and let the man be born”.
Jon must let go of his innocence and weakness,
must make hard choices, and “do
the things that must be done”.
So Jon makes tough decisions. He sends his best
friend Sam far away to the south to become a
maester. Sam doesn’t want to go, so Jon forces
Sam to leave. Sam feels that Jon has changed,
he’s not Jon any more, he’s become “Lord Snow”,
a harsh cold leader. Many characters call him
“Lord Snow” now. It started as Alliser’s
mocking nickname, but now the name is a
source of strength – just like Tyrion suggested.
Jon also sends Aemon south. Because Melisandre
wants people with kings’ blood so she can burn
them in magic rituals – Aemon has king’s blood,
because he’s a Targaryen – so Jon sends Aemon
south to save him from Melisandre. Even though
Jon knows that Aemon’s so old that he
might die on this journey. And he does.
And Jon makes another harsh decision – he sends
Gilly south, but he secretly forces Gilly to
abandon her baby, and to instead take Mance
and Dalla’s baby south. Because King Mance’s
baby also has king’s blood – Melisandre might
burn him. So to save him, Jon secretly swaps
the babies. Gilly begs Jon to let her keep her
child, and Jon does feel terrible, but Lord Snow
stays strong, and cold, does what must be done.
Jon promises to protect Gilly’s baby – like how
Ned promised to protect Lyanna’s baby. Jon
says goodbye to Sam and Aemon and Gilly,
and remembers saying goodbye to Robb. Jon
keeps losing the people closest to him.
Leadership makes Jon isolated. As Lord Commander,
he has to be an authority, above his men,
so he feels he can’t hang out with his friends
any more. Jon sends Grenn and Pyp and Edd away
to other castles, leaving Jon alone, friendless,
and vulnerable. He no longer has the advice or
protection of loyal friends when he needs them.
Jon resigns himself to a cold, lonely life,
and focusses on his duty. Jon often works all
night, barely sleeping. Maybe on some level, Jon
is punishing himself – out of guilt for Ygritte.
Jon also spends a lot of time training at combat,
cause he wants to be a better swordsman.
In the books so far, Jon isn’t a great
warrior. But this training could make Jon
a much better fighter in the final battles.
Janos disobeys Jon’s orders. So Jon executes
Janos. Like Ned, Jon looks in the man’s eyes,
hears his last words, and then cuts off his
head. Previously, Jon chose not to kill Ygritte
and chose not to kill that old man – but this
time he does kill – Lord Commander Snow won’t
tolerate defiance. But killing Janos is also
personal – cause Janos tried to get Jon killed,
and Janos betrayed Ned, so killing Janos is
revenge. There’s still tension between Jon’s duty
to the Night’s Watch and his love for the Starks.
Stannis and Melisandre execute Mance Rayder by
burning him alive. –Though in the books, this is a
magic illusion, and Mance is secretly still alive,
working for Melisandre. Stannis lets a thousand
wildlings through the Wall. Melisandre makes them
burn a piece of weirwood to symbolise accepting
R’hllor as their god. And Stannis shows off his
glowing sword Lightbringer. Melisandre says
that Stannis is the prophesied hero Azor Ahai.
But Jon sees that Stannis’ sword is not the real
Lightbringer. So if Stannis is not the messiah,
who is? Jon did have that dream of fighting the
dead with a burning sword. And when Melisandre
looks in her flames for a glimpse
of Azor Ahai, she sees Jon “Snow”.
Many in the Night’s Watch hate wildlings,
think they’re all evil barbarians. But Jon
learned that wildlings are just people, some
good and some bad, like anyone else. The Watch
protects the realms of men – and “what are these
wildlings, if not men?”. Jon says all the living
must unite against the white walkers. So Jon
settles the thousand wildlings at Mole’s Town,
and he personally brings them food. In the same
book, Daenerys brings food to refugees, while
she tries to make peace and unity. Jon and Dany
both risk their own lives to end war and protect
vulnerable people. Jon convinces some wildlings
to join the Night’s Watch. He even brings a
giant named Wun Wun to the Wall. So with bravery
and compassion, Jon turns enemies into allies.
Jon gives Stannis advice to help him take the
north. He tells Stannis to rally the mountain
clans, and to take Deepwood Motte, before he
attacks the Boltons at Winterfell. Jon isn’t
supposed to help Stannis – the Night’s Watch is
meant to be neutral in southern wars. But the
Boltons and Lannisters destroyed Jon’s family
– he wants Stannis to defeat them. So again,
there’s tension between Jon’s Night’s Watch duty
and his love for the Starks. Stannis offers again
to make Jon a Stark, he says the north would
follow Ned’s son – and Jon clearly knows a lot
about northern politics, he’d be a good Lord of
Winterfell. But again Jon reluctantly refuses.
So Stannis and his army march off to war, but he
leaves Melisandre and his daughter Shireen and his
wife Selyse at the Wall. Which is another headache
for Jon, cause Selyse is a pain in the arse.
Melisandre is a priestess of the fire god R’hllor.
She sees visions of the future in her flames,
and she warns Jon that he’s in danger from
“daggers in the dark”. She tells Jon to use her
magic power. But Jon doesn’t trust Melisandre.
He doesn’t trust magic. So Melisandre tries to
prove her power – Melisandre has a vision
that three of Jon’s rangers will be killed,
with their eyes gouged out. And this vision comes
true. Maybe Jon should listen to Melisandre.
Then Melisandre has a vision of “A girl in grey
on a dying horse”. And she says this girl is
Jon’s sister Arya. Cause at Winterfell, Ramsay
Bolton marries a girl who he says is Arya Stark.
The girl actually isn’t Arya, she’s a girl called
Jeyne who the Boltons say is Arya, but Jon doesn’t
know that. So Jon wants to save his sister from
the monstrous Ramsay. But he can’t do it himself,
cause his duty is on the Wall – so Melisandre
says she’ll help, by sending Mance Rayder.
So Melisandre pretended to burn Mance,
but that was a trick. He’s actually alive,
in a magic disguise, apparently under Melisandre’s
control. So Melisandre and Jon send Mance on a
secret mission – Mance and six wilding women go
to Winterfell to save Arya. It’s heroic for Jon
to try to save his sister, but it’s also risky –
the Commander of the Night’s Watch is not meant
to secretly plot with the wildling king, or
to take a northman’s wife. Watch men aren’t
allowed to help their sisters, only their Watch
brothers. Jon is putting love ahead of his duty.
And it turns out Melisandre is wrong about her
vision. A girl in grey does arrive at Castle
Black, but it’s not Arya – it’s Alys Karstark,
the heir to House Karstark. Alys’ uncle Cregan
wants to forcibly marry Alys, to take over House
Karstark – and he’s planning to betray Stannis for
the Boltons. So this is another moral dilemma
for Jon. Cause the Night’s Watch is not meant
to interfere in politics. But Alys begs Jon
for help, and she reminds him of Arya. So Jon
imprisons Cregan, and he warns Stannis of the
betrayal, and he sets up a different marriage
for Alys. Jon marries Alys to Sigorn, the new
leader of the Thenn wildlings. The wildlings
will help Alys claim Karhold. And Jon hopes this
marriage will create unity between wildlings and
the north. At the wedding, Watch men and wildlings
dance together – it’s a beautiful moment of joy
and peace between former enemies. But politically,
this is dangerous. Many northmen will be outraged
that the Watch married a northern girl to
a wildling, and helped wildlings take over
a northern castle. And by imprisoning Cregan, and
warning Stannis, Jon has undermined Roose Bolton,
the Warden of the North, the ally of King
Tommen. Jon has to make bold changes to
prepare for the white walkers. But his radical
decisions, his political interference and his
personal biases put the Night’s Watch in danger.
The Night’s Watch has lots of problems. They’ve
been in decline for centuries. They don’t have
enough men. They lost their best leaders like
Benjen, Qhorin and Aemon. And after hosting
Stannis and the wildlings, they don’t have
enough food for winter. So Jon finds solutions. He
meets with Tycho Nestoris, from the Iron Bank – in
the book, Tycho has a Big Purple Hat. And Jon
borrows money from the Bank to buy food. He also
plans to build greenhouses to grow vegetables in
winter. He plans to build beacons along the Wall
to communicate. Most of the Wall’s castles are
abandoned, so Jon starts manning them with Watch
men and wildlings. Jon trains his men on archery
instead of on swords, cause archery’s more useful
for defending the Wall. Jon talks to Wun Wun to
learn about the giants. And he wants to learn
about the white walkers and their zombies, so Jon
locks up some corpses to see if they rise from the
dead, to try to talk to them. Jon has lots of
smart and creative ideas in the book. Compare
that to the TV show, where Jon is a brave himbo
who just fights bad guys and looks sad. And TV
Jon is stubbornly honest, he “cannot lie”. But
book Jon does lie, and has secrets. Like when
he swaps the babies. Like when he sends Mance to
Winterfell. He also sends Val to go find Tormund,
even though Jon promised Stannis that he wouldn’t.
Jon doesn’t like breaking his word, he wants to be
honourable, but he feels that saving the realm
is more important than his honour. Sometimes a
lie is the right thing to do. The TV show
gives Jon morally uncomplicated conflicts,
battles against evil. But book Jon grapples
with difficult ambiguous moral questions.
Jon also makes change and justice. Cause
Benjen said that everyone in the Watch has
equal opportunities, you get what you earn –
but that’s not true. Waymar Royce gets special
privileges because his dad is a lord. Most of the
powerful positions in the Watch go to trueborn men
from noble families – the Watch isn’t fair. So
Jon changes this by giving important positions
to lowborn people. Jon makes a wildling the new
master-at-arms. He gives command of a castle to
a lowborn guy. And Jon mentors a boy named Satin.
Satin was a sex worker, and some men hate him for
being a boy “whore”. But Jon sees that Satin is
smart and brave. So Jon makes Satin his personal
steward, potentially training Satin for command.
Because as a bastard, Jon experienced prejudice
and injustice. He saw how people like Arya and Sam
are discriminated against for being different. So
as Commander, Jon makes the Watch more fair and
more effective – judging people on their ability
instead of their social class. These changes anger
the more traditional men in the Watch. Bowen Marsh
complains – making change also makes enemies.
Beyond the Wall, Tormund leads thousands of
wildlings desperate to escape the white walkers.
So Jon plans to let them through the Wall. He’ll
house them in castles along the Wall, to help
fight the walkers. He takes all the wildlings’
wealth, including a fancy ivory dildo. And to
keep the wildlings loyal, he’ll take a hundred
boys as hostages. So the wildlings are angry
at Jon’s price. And the Watch officers are also
outraged. These men dedicated their lives to
fighting wildlings. Bowen was recently wounded
by wildlings in battle. So Bowen says it’s
treason to let the enemy through the Wall. Jon
insists they must unite everyone against the white
walkers. So he’ll let all the wildlings through,
even the brutal raiders who gouged the eyes out of
those rangers. Jon is determined to save everyone,
but he fails to compromise, and fails to
convince important people of his plan. He
doesn’t communicate well – he doesn’t even tell
First Steward Bowen about his loan from the Iron
Bank. So Jon makes political mistakes.
There’re also thousands of wildlings
at a village called Hardhome. In the TV
show, Jon leads a mission to save them,
and he kills a white walker. But that doesn’t
happen in the books. In the book, Jon sends
some men to save the wildlings, and we hear it
goes badly – there’s “Dead things in the water”.
Ultimately, Jon lets the wildlings through the
Wall. And in the TV show, that’s why Alliser and
the Watch men kill Jon. Jon does the right thing
and he dies for it – it’s morally uncomplicated
in the show. But in the book, there’s more to it.
In the book, Jon gets a letter from Ramsay Bolton.
Ramsay says that Stannis is dead, defeated in
battle. Ramsay says he has Mance prisoner and
accuses Jon stealing his bride. Cause with the
help of Mance’s wildlings, the fake Arya escapes
Winterfell. So Ramsay demands that Jon give
him Arya and Val and Selyse and Melisandre,
or else he’ll “cut out” Jon’s “bastard’s heart
and eat it”. There’re lots of theories about
this letter, like that Stannis isn’t really dead,
and that maybe someone other than Ramsay wrote
the letter. But this letter is a huge threat to
the Night’s Watch, and it’s kind of Jon’s fault.
Cause as Commander of the Watch, Jon was meant to
be politically neutral. But Jon helped Stannis,
and helped Alys, and sent Mance to take Ramsay’s
wife. Because of Jon’s bias for Stannis and the
Starks, he brings the wrath of the Boltons upon
the Watch. All through Book 5, Jon tried to
balance love and duty, but this letter forces him
to choose. Will he submit to Ramsay to save the
Watch, or will he fight for Arya and Winterfell?
Jon thinks about Robb and Bran and Rickon and
Sansa and Arya. And he decides to fight. Jon
publicly reads Ramsay’s letter, revealing his
secret Mance plot, and Jon declares that he’ll
“ride south” to fight Ramsay at Winterfell. He
also says Tormund will lead the Watch on another
wildly dangerous mission to Hardhome. So the
wildlings rally behind Jon. But the Night’s Watch
are furious – Jon is publicly breaking his oath,
deserting the Wall, involving the Night’s Watch in
a war. And that’s why Jon is killed in the books.
First, there’s a distraction – the giant Wun
Wun kills a knight called Ser Patrek. And this
is a hidden reference to football – the giant
represents one of George Martin’s favourite
teams the New York Giants. And Ser Patrek
represents George’s friend Patrick St Denis,
who supports the Dallas Cowboys – the Cowboys
logo is a blue star, so Patrek’s heraldry is
a blue star. And this football easter
egg happens right before Jon is killed.
Jon tries to calm everyone down, but in the
chaos, Bowen Marsh and three others stab Jon,
and Jon falls, bleeding, in the snow.
The killing of Jon Snow is similar to the
killing of ancient Roman leader Julius Caesar
– Jon and Caesar are both seen as a political
threat, so they’re stabbed to death by their own
men. Even small details of the attacks are the
same. And George is a fan of Roman history, and
of Shakespeare’s Caesar play, so he was clearly
taking inspiration here. Caesar was killed on the
Ides of March. And Jon is stabbed by Bowen Marsh.
So some fans call Jon’s killing the Ides of Marsh.
In the TV show, Jon’s assassination is led by the
cruel and vindictive Alliser Thorne. But in the
books, it’s led by Bowen. And Bowen doesn’t hate
Jon. Bowen is not evil. Even Jon thinks that
Bowen is a “good man”. When Bowen stabs Jon,
Bowen cries. He feels he’s forced to kill Jon,
for the Watch. Cause Jon did break his oath, and
endanger the Watch, out of love for the Starks.
So in Book 5, Jon makes tough moral choices,
plotting and politicking to save lives,
make peace, protect the realm. He tries to
balance duty with love – helping Arya and Alys and
Stannis. But when Jon’s forced to choose between
the Watch and the Starks, he chooses love. Love is
the death of duty. And it’s the death of Jon Snow.
So what happens next?
George Martin is still
writing the next books to finish the series. But
there’s lots of foreshadowing and theories about
what will happen in The Winds of Winter.
In the TV show, Jon gets resurrected. When
he comes back to life, he’s tired and
sad, borderline suicidal for a while,
but his personality is mostly the same. In the
books, death will change Jon. George Martin says
death is a “transformative experience”, his
“characters who come back from death” have
“lost something”. When Beric Dondarrion dies and
is resurrected, he loses his memories and his
identity. When Catelyn dies and is resurrected,
she becomes a scary zombie called Lady Stoneheart,
who’s consumed with hate and revenge. George says
if someone suffers a “violent, traumatic death,
they’re not going to come back as nice
as ever”. So how will death change Jon?
In the TV show, Jon’s resurrection is
simple – Melisandre gives him a prayer
and a --haircut -- and he comes back to life.
But in the books, Jon’s resurrection will be
complicated. Cause there are hints that Jon’s
soul will go inside his direwolf, Ghost. The
books explain that when a skinchanger dies, their
spirit can live on in their animal – it’s called
a “second life”. We saw Orell live on in his eagle
after he died. Then we see the skinchanger Varamyr
live on in his wolf. Varamyr thinks that Jon
is a powerful warg, and that Ghost “would be
a second life worthy of a king”. Melisandre has
a vision of Jon being “a man”, then “a wolf”,
then “a man again” – hinting that Jon will live
inside Ghost for a while, then he’ll come back in
his human body. In Book 5, Jon’s connection with
Ghost gets “stronger”, he feels that he and Ghost
are “one”. And when Jon is stabbed, his last word
is “Ghost”. So these are strong hints that Jon’s
ghost will live in Ghost for a while. Why?
The books say that skinchanging changes your
personality, it makes you more like your animal.
When someone has a second life in their wolf,
their human memory slowly fades, til “only the
beast remains”. So being in Ghost could make
Jon less human, and more wolfish. Ned says that
Brandon and Lyanna Stark had “The wolf blood”,
making them wild and reckless. Jon is sometimes
aggressive and impulsive in the books – he attacks
Alliser twice, and has a violent outburst in
training. Usually Jon controls these emotions,
supresses his desires – he thinks “I am a man, not
a wolf”. But being murdered and then soul-merged
with his beast might finally unleash Jon’s wolf
blood, making him a more reckless, dangerous
character, more focussed on his own desires.
This would be similar to Daenerys’ storyline.
Cause in Book 5, like Jon, Daenerys tries to
make peace. She suppresses her own desires for
the sake of politics and the greater good. But at
the end of the book, like Jon, she has a downfall,
and this crisis changes her. As she wanders
the Dothraki Sea alone, she has visions from
Quaithe that remind her of her Targaryen identity.
Daenerys rejects peace and embraces her desires
for “Fire and Blood”, and to go home to Westeros.
So Jon might embrace his desires to go home to
Winterfell. And Jon could also have visions.
He’s already had visions from Bloodraven,
and from Bran, through Ghost. So maybe as a
spirit in Ghost, he’ll have more visions. Jon
could find out that Bran and Rickon are still
alive. Bloodraven could tell him his destiny to
become King in the North and to defeat the white
walkers. To fulfil the prophecy of Azor Ahai.
Visions could reveal secrets, unlock power,
give Jon new purpose to pursue his destiny.
Though, in this world, visions and dreams
can be destructive. Sinister forces might
use visions to influence people. Can Jon trust
his visions, or is Bloodraven manipulating him?
Jon’s spirit could stay in Ghost for a while.
Maybe as a wolf, he’ll roam beyond the Wall,
and find uncle Benjen, or learn the secrets
of the white walkers. He could go to Hardhome,
or help Bran come south. He could have lots of
adventures, gallivanting through the woods in
the brain of wolf, tripping on vision… But Jon
won’t be a dog forever.☹ Eventually he’ll be
resurrected in his human body, and like in the
TV show, it’ll probably be Melisandre who does
it – in the book, Melisandre says you’ll “have
grave need of me”, and “I am your only hope”.
When Jon is resurrected, there might be a
cost. Cause when Beric resurrects Stoneheart,
Beric dies. When Mirri heals Drogo, Daenerys’
baby dies. When Daenerys hatches dragons,
Mirri dies. Melisandre says “Only death can
pay for life”, “A great gift requires a great
sacrifice”. So what sacrifice will pay for Jon’s
life? Maybe Melisandre will sacrifice herself. Or
maybe Ghost will die – if Jon and Ghost’s spirits
are merged together, will there be anything left
of Ghost to live in Ghost’s body? Melisandre says
king’s blood is a particularly powerful sacrifice,
so maybe the sacrifice will be King Mance or
King Stannis or Princess Shireen. Melisandre
prophesies that king’s blood will wake a dragon
from stone. And Shireen has stony greyscale. So
maybe the dragon is Jon Targaryen, awoken from
the sacrifice of stony Shireen. It’s also possible
that no one will die. Cause when Thoros resurrects
Beric, no one dies. Instead, the cost is Beric’s
humanity – he loses his memories and identity.
So maybe it’ll be the same with Jon – he’ll come
back to life, but at the cost of his soul.
In the TV show, after his resurrection,
Jon looks the same. Just with some sexy new scars.
But in the books, Jon’s appearance might change.
Cause when Catelyn is resurrected, her hair goes
white, and her eyes go red. Theon’s hair goes
white after his symbolic death and rebirth. So
maybe Jon will also get white hair and red eyes,
cause that would have a lot of symbolic
meaning. Ghost has white hair and red eyes,
like Bloodraven and the weirwoods. White hair
would make Jon look more like a Targaryen,
like his father Rhaegar. And red eyes would be
like Melisandre’s red eyes, connecting Jon to
the fire god R’hllor. George says that Beric is “a
wight animated by fire instead of by ice”. So will
Jon be a fire wight? Or will he be an ice wight,
like Coldhands? Maybe Bloodraven and Melisandre’s
magic could both help resurrect Jon, combining
the old gods and R’hllor, Stark and Targaryen,
making Jon a wight of ice and fire.
Patchface calls Jon “The crow” and says
“Under the sea the crows are white as snow” –
‘under the sea’ is a metaphor for death – so
this could be a hint that undead Jon will have
white hair and pale skin. When Jon was a kid,
he once covered himself in flour to make
himself “pale white” like a ghost. In the
TV show, they call Jon the White Wolf.
So there are lots of hints that Jon’s
death will give him pale skin, white hair,
and red eyes, showing that he’s not just
back to normal – he’s changed, he’s undead.
There are perks to being undead. Beric and
Coldhands and Melisandre don’t need to eat or
sleep. It could be useful for Jon to not eat
or sleep if he has to fight a war, or travel
north. But there are also downsides to being
undead. Beric loses memories, Stoneheart can
hardly speak. They look like ugly scary zombies,
wounded and rotted, their hearts don’t beat. Will
Jon become a hideous zombie? If his heart doesn’t
beat, will his penis still work? That could be
disappointing for Daenerys. One theory is that
after he’s killed, Jon’s corpse will be kept in
an ice cell in the Wall. Bran has a vision of Jon
“sleeping” in a “cold bed” with his skin going
pale and cold. Aemon says that the cold of the
Wall preserves. So an ice cell might prevent Jon’s
body from rotting. And unlike Beric and Catelyn,
Jon is a warg – his spirit won’t die, it’ll
live on in Ghost – so maybe that will protect
his mind and memories. So Jon won’t be too
much of a zombie. But he will be changed.
Aemon said “Kill the boy and let the man be
born”. Jon the boy has been killed – so what
new man will be born? Living in Ghost could
unleash his wolf blood, make him more violent
and reckless. He might have visions from
Bloodraven giving him revelations and new
purpose. He might look different, with white
hair and red eyes – a wight of ice and fire.
The Night’s Watch oath says my watch won’t
end “until my death”. So after Jon’s death,
he’s arguably free from his vows, he can leave the
Watch. So what will Jon do in The Winds of Winter?
After Catelyn and Beric’s resurrections, they
focus on their final missions – Catelyn wants
revenge for the Red Wedding, Beric fights in the
riverlands – George says that purpose “is part
of what’s animating him”. So after Jon’s
resurrection, he might be focussed on his
final mission – fight Ramsay, save Arya, and
take Winterfell. He can finally do what he’s
wanted to do since Book 1 – ride south.
In the TV show, Stannis dies, and Jon
fights the Battle of the Bastards to beat the
Boltons and take Winterfell. But in the books,
it might be Stannis who defeats the Boltons –
there are hints that he’ll fake his own death,
and will win a battle on a frozen lake.
So by the time Jon gets to Winterfell,
Stannis might’ve already won the war.
There could be multiple battles,
Jon might fight Ramsay later. The Stark
direwolves might be involved, symbolising
Jon reuniting with his Stark wolf pack. But if
Jon does fight the Boltons, it won’t be like
the TV show – it won’t just be Jon surviving
through dumb luck, and punching Ramsay in the
face twenty-one times. Like all of book Jon’s
conflicts, it’ll be a moral and emotional test.
In the TV show, Ramsay has Jon’s brother Rickon,
and Jon tries to save Rickon, but Rickon dies
anyway. There’s no meaningful choice or lesson
here for TV Jon, Rickon’s death just happens.
Maybe in the book, Jon will make a moral choice.
Like, maybe Ramsay will tell Jon not to attack
or else he’ll kill Rickon, but since Jon is now
more reckless, and because he wants Winterfell,
Jon attacks anyway, and causes Rickon’s death.
This would show that Jon has changed – that
he’s willing to risk innocent lives to get what he
wants. And this could also create conflict between
Jon and Sansa, who might blame Jon for Rickon’s
death. Jon could finally reclaim the home of the
Starks, but at the cost of alienating his Stark
siblings, losing the very family he always wanted.
This is just speculation. But Jon’s battles in
The Winds of Winter will explore what kind of
person he’s become after his resurrection.
What will Jon sacrifice to take Winterfell?
Once the Boltons are defeated, Stannis might go
to the Nightfort and die, possibly killed by white
walkers after he sacrifices Shireen. So who will
rule Winterfell and the north? In the TV show,
the northern lords make Jon the King in
the North. Even though it should be Sansa
who gets Winterfell, because she’s the eldest
known surviving trueborn Stark – in the show,
the lords ignore the line of succession
and make Jon king just because he’s a
cool guy. But in the books, Jon has an actual
legal claim to Winterfell. Cause in Book 3,
Robb Stark wants Jon to be his heir as King in the
North. He considers legitimising Jon, to make him
a true Stark not a bastard. So Robb writes a will,
and the books don’t show us what the will says,
but it probably names Jon as the next King
in the North. Not everyone knows about Robb’s
will. But Maege Mormont and Galbart Glover know,
and they go to Howland Reed in the Neck. Howland
was at the tower of joy, where Jon was born, so
he might know about Jon’s real parents. Maege’s
daughter is with Stannis’ army, with the mountain
clansmen. And two clan leaders visit Jon – and
Jon suspects that these guys have some secret
purpose. Edmure also knows about Robb’s will,
and two of Edmure’s men go to the Wall. Stoneheart
knows about Robb’s will, and has Robb’s crown,
and she travels to the Neck where Howland and
Maege and Galbart are. So there’s a theory that
there’s a conspiracy to make Jon King in the
North. Cause “The north remembers” Ned Stark’s
legacy of leadership, and Jon is seen as the heir
to that legacy. That’s why Alys Karstark comes to
Jon, because he’s Ned Stark’s son – that means
something in the north. So these northmen might
reveal Robb’s will and declare Jon King in the
North. The problem with that is that there are two
other northern conspiracies happening. Lord Wyman
Manderly plans to make Rickon Lord of Winterfell.
Littlefinger plans to use Sansa and the Vale
to claim the north. Plus Bran is still alive,
and the real Arya will return. And all of these
Starks arguably have a better claim to Winterfell
than Jon does. Robb’s will was written on the
assumption that Bran and Rickon were dead. So is
Robb’s will definitive? Does a legitimised bastard
like Jon come before a trueborn child like Sansa?
The laws of succession in Westeros are vague
and subjective. And there are lots of different
political factions at play here. This could be
a messy inheritance struggle, dividing the Stark
family – and creating deep conflict within Jon.
He’ll be torn between his loyalty to his siblings,
and his desire to be the Stark of Winterfell.
In the TV show, Jon doesn’t want to be King
in the North. It’s another thing that just
happens to TV Jon, without his choice. Then
there’s this weird conflict where Sansa is
envious of Jon, and Arya threatens to kill
Sansa. It’s one of the worst plotlines in the
show, partly because Jon has no agency or stakes
in the conflict cause he doesn’t want Winterfell.
In the books, Jon does want Winterfell. As a boy,
“he used to dream that one day Winterfell might
be his”. Jon has a dream where he cuts off Robb’s
head and screams “I am the Lord of Winterfell”.
When Stannis offers him Winterfell, Jon wants
it more than anything. And his resurrection
could make him more focussed on his desires.
Jon could be a great King in the North. He’s a
smart and compassionate leader. He knows about
northern politics, he’s respected by northmen.
He wants to make peace and unify against the
white walkers. There’s lots of foreshadowing that
Jon will be a king – it seems like his destiny.
But becoming King in the North will have a
cost. He might get Rickon killed, or piss off
Sansa. He might get lots of wildings killed in
battle. And the Night’s Watch could fall apart
without him. To become the Stark of Winterfell,
Jon might lose his families – lose the Watch,
and the wildlings, and the Starks – without
them, what’s the point of having Winterfell?
Jon was never close with Sansa or Rickon.
But he loves Arya. Throughout the books,
Jon and Arya miss each other often, and try to
reunite. Jon dies largely because he wants to
save Arya. So it’ll be super emotional when
finally get back together. In the TV show,
this is a mostly happy reunion. But in
the books, it could be darker and sadder.
Cause Jon and Arya have been through so much.
Arya suffered at Harrenhal, joined a death cult,
murdered people, and she’s still just eleven
years old. Jon lost his lover, fought in battles,
got murdered. They’re both traumatised by death,
and have lost their identities. Jon is not just
Jon the bastard, he’s now an undead Stark king,
he’s “Lord Snow”. And Arya has changed her name
and her face so many times that she’s not Arya,
she’s “no one”. Jon and Arya have changed so much,
they might not recognise each other.
In the books, characters often don’t recognise
each other. Like, Theon and Asha don’t recognise
each other. It shows how characters have changed,
exploring themes of identity and perception.
Arya is constantly not recognised by people. And
she specifically worries that Jon won’t recognise
her. And Jon wonders if he’ll recognise Arya.
Jon has already met a fake Arya – he thought Alys
was Arya, but she wasn’t. Ramsay’s wife Jeyne is
another fake Arya. So when Jon finally meets the
real Arya, he might think she’s another fake. They
could recognise each other later, but the point
could be that after everything that they’ve been
through, Jon and Arya can’t have their
happy innocent relationship ever again.
So Winterfell might not be the happy
homecoming Jon wanted. The Starks have changed,
the family may be divided. Jon’s identity will
still be uncertain, torn between the Starks,
the Watch, the wildlings – and his hidden
Targaryen identity haunting his dreams.
Maybe Jon will abdicate as King in the
North, and let Sansa rule instead. Cause
Jon has more wars to fight. The white walkers
are coming. And Daenerys will arrive with her
dragons. In A Dream of Spring, Jon will
fight the final battles of ice and fire.
In the TV show, Jon and Daenerys fall in love.
There are hints this’ll happen in the books,
too – Daenerys has a vision of a blue flower on a
wall of ice filling the air with sweetness – the
flower could be Jon, because his mother Lyanna
loved blue roses, and the sweetness could be
Jon and Daenerys’ love. Jon and Dany have a lot
in common. They’re both young leaders who want
to protect people. They both want family and
home. They’ve both suffered trauma and loss,
and transformative magic. Jon is attracted
to confident, capable women like Ygritte,
like Val – like Dany. And Daenerys is attracted
to bad boy warriors with great hair like Drogo
and Daario. Jon may be more violent and have
cooler hair after his resurrection. So it makes
sense that Jon and Dany could fall in love. They
also work as a political alliance – King Jon and
Queen Daenerys could unite the north and south.
Icy Jon and fiery Daenerys fit the series’ title,
A Song of Ice and Fire. Daenerys’ dragons are
the perfect weapon to destroy the army of the
dead. So together they could burn the white
walkers, get married, have babies, and rule
Westeros happily ever after. What could go wrong?
Jon will learn the truth about his parents – that
he’s not Ned’s bastard, he’s the son of
Lyanna Stark and Prince Rhaegar Targaryen.
Jon is arguably the rightful King of
Westeros. And if Rhaegar and Lyanna
secretly got married like in the TV show,
Jon is a trueborn Targaryen, not a bastard.
There’re a few ways Jon could discover this.
Howland Reed might tell Jon. Cause Howland
was there when Jon was born, and George Martin
has teased that Howland will be important. Or
maybe Benjen will tell Jon about his parents.
It would be more emotionally impactful for Jon
to learn the truth from his beloved uncle. Benjen
and Howland were both at the Harrenhal tourney,
where Rhaegar and Lyanna probably got
together, so they could tell Jon what
his parents’ relationship was really like.
Like in the TV show, Jon may learn this in
the Winterfell crypts. Jon has those recurring
dreams of the crypts, where he’s “searching for
his father”, and he has to come down here. There
are theories that Jon will find proof of his
parents in the crypts – like Rhaegar’s harp,
or a hidden message in Lyanna’s tomb. There
are rumours of hidden dragon eggs in the crypts.
Which could be a metaphor for Jon discovering his
dragon identity. George uses the same metaphor
with Egg ‘hatching’ into a Targaryen. And Jon
discovering his identity in the stone crypts
could fulfil the prophecy of a dragon waking
from stone – Jon will enter the crypts as Ned’s
bastard, and will emerge a Targaryen dragon.
So what will the truth of his parents mean to him?
Jon might be angry that Ned lied to him, that he
was never a bastard. He might be horrified that
his mother Lyanna was a teenager who died birthing
him, and that Prince Rhaegar hooked up with her
probably to fulfil a prophecy, sparking a war
that killed thousands. Jon’s grandfather was the
evil Mad King – that’s like finding out your dad
is Darth Vader. And Jon’s lover Daenerys is his
aunt – which is like finding out Princess Leia is
your sister. It’s like poetry, it rhymes.
In the TV show, Jon doesn’t want to be a
Targaryen. But for this revelation to have
meaning, it’s gotta have some impact on Jon.
Cause Jon’s story is a search for identity. He
felt rejected from the Starks, and that’s why
he joined the Night’s Watch, why he was tempted
by the wildlings, and by Stannis’ offer. Being
a Targaryen could finally give Jon a family –
he’d be royalty, alongside Queen Daenerys, with
ancestral homes at King’s Landing and Dragonstone.
In the show, Jon gets a new name, Aegon Targaryen.
In the books, there’s already several Aegons, so
Jon’s name might be Aemon or Jaehaerys Targaryen.
Even as a child, Jon felt connected to Targaryens.
He idolised King Daeron Targaryen. Maester Aemon
Targaryen was Jon’s beloved mentor. And with
Daenerys he could further explore his Targaryen
side. Jon could bond with the dragon Rhaegal,
who was named after Jon’s father Rhaegar. When
Jon rides Rhaegal in flight, experiences that joy
and power, he may embrace a Targaryen identity. In
the books, there’s a magical connection between
dragon and rider. Jon might start to have dragon
dreams – visions of future triumph and doom. Cause
dragons represent the intoxicating lure of power,
of ambition and destruction. Dragons
could wake the fire in Jon’s blood,
connecting him to his Targaryen heritage
and to Daenerys’ war for the Throne.
In the TV show, Jon doesn’t want to be King of
Westeros. But book Jon might want his rightful
Throne. Because he’s always wanted justice, and
to protect the innocent. With the wildlings,
he learned a whole new political ideology of
freedom and equality. And he has increasingly
used political power to make change. In Book
5, he tries to unite the north to save the
world – but he fails cause he doesn’t have
enough power. If Jon took the Iron Throne
as a Targaryen dragon king, maybe then he could
unite the realm, save the world, and do justice.
Much like Jon’s great-great-grandfather, King Egg,
Aegon the Fifth. Egg also wanted to do justice and
to protect the vulnerable, but he was frustrated
by rebellions. So Egg tried to get dragons so he
could use their power for good. But, in the end,
Egg’s quest for dragons led to death and tragedy
at Summerhall. Daenerys also seems headed for
destruction, despite her good intentions. So
like other Targaryens, Jon will be tempted by the
power of fire and blood, embodied by his dragon
Rhaegal. He’ll want to use this power for good
– but he’ll see that dragons are destructive,
they kill innocent people, “fire burns”.
In the TV show, Daenerys fights a war against
Cersei. But in the books, she might fight
Young Griff, a “false dragon” who claims
to be a Targaryen. Their war could be a new
Dance of the Dragons – “And everywhere the
dragons danced the people died”. Daenerys’
war will cause death and devastation. So Jon
will ask himself – is it okay to kill innocent
people to win the throne? He may be tempted to
make sacrifices so he can rule. But Jon will also
think of Ned Stark’s morality. Ned taught justice,
mercy, to protect the innocent. Donal taught Jon
empathy for common folk. The wildlings taught him
the precious fleeting beauty of life. If Jon burns
thousands to save the realm, what has he saved,
and what has he become? This is a moral struggle,
and it’s also a question of identity. Is Jon
destined to be a fiery Targaryen because he has
Rhaegar’s blood, or can he choose to be like Ned,
the father who raised Jon? This is the song of
ice and fire, the battle within Jon’s heart.
Jon might also be tempted by Melisandre. In
Book 5, Melisandre urges Jon to use her magic
and visions. Jon doesn’t trust Melisandre at
first, but throughout the book, she gradually
wins him over. She makes a bunch of correct
predictions – so in his last chapter, Jon wants
to use Melisandre’s visions. When Jon is killed
by “daggers in the dark”, and resurrected by
Melisandre, that will prove her power even more.
In the TV show, after Stannis dies, Melisandre
says Jon is the prophesied hero Azor Ahai.
TV Jon is not interested in the prophecy,
but book Jon might listen. Cause book Jon reads
about Azor Ahai. He dreams of fighting the dead
with a flaming sword. After he’s reborn,
as a fire wight, with the magic of R’hllor,
he may believe he’s destined to save
the world. Like Rhaegar did before him.
So Jon may accept Melisandre’s help. She
could help him understand the prophecy,
and how to use its power. But unfortunately, her
help often involves burning innocent people alive
and killing your own brother with magic shadows.
Her advice leads Stannis down a dark path that
will probably destroy him. And Melisandre is
often wrong about her visions – her power is
treacherous. And her religion is dangerous.
In the TV show, after Jon’s resurrection,
Tormund says people think Jon is a “god”. Then the
show drops that idea. But in the books, religion
is increasingly important. The sparrows rise and
imprison Queen Cersei. The eastern red priests say
Daenerys is Azor Ahai, and demand a holy war. At
Castle Black, Melisandre has religious followers,
including Baratheon knights, and some Watch men
and wildlings. So when Jon miraculously rises from
the dead, he could be seen as a religious messiah.
Fanatical followers could rally behind him, giving
him the power to unite armies, to win wars. But
the red god is hungry and jealous, demanding human
sacrifice and the destruction of other religions.
Daenerys might also ally with red priests. Which
could lead to religious war in Westeros, between
Jon and Dany with the red god, and Young Griff
with the Faith of the Seven. If Jon uses the power
of Melisandre and R’hllor, he’s playing with fire.
So Jon will be torn between Targaryen
R’hlloric fire power, and his icy Stark
morality. And this war for his heart will
climax when he faces the white walkers.
While Jon is in the south, things will get bad
at the Wall. The Night’s Watch could fall apart.
Stannis is doomed. And the Wall will fall. In the
TV show, the white walkers use a zombie dragon to
break the Wall. In the books it might be Euron
who breaks the Wall, with the Horn of Winter,
or by stealing one of Dany’s dragons. But the
Wall will fall, and the dead will march south.
In the TV show, the battle against the
white walkers lasts one night, one episode,
at Winterfell. But in the books, this could be a
long, grinding, apocalyptic conflict that ravages
Westeros. The previous Long Night is said to
have “lasted a generation” – years of cold
and sunless skies, causing mass starvation.
This darkness might be caused by a meteor
strike – there are legends of fallen stars and
comets associated with the Long Night. There
are tales of the white walkers hunting humans
with giant ice spiders as well as their zombie
hordes. So the Long Night could be a dark magical
apocalypse – “An age of wonder and terror”, “for
gods and heroes”. The world will need a saviour.
In the TV show, Arya kills the white walkers. But
in the books, Jon is set up as the hero. He
swore the Watch oath, he’s fought the dead,
he’s had those prophetic dreams. So
how will he stop the white walkers?
In the TV show, the good guys all unite for a
big battle and destroy the white walkers. But
is this what the books are leading up to? George
Martin criticises simplistic stories of good guys
fighting bad guys – he said “We don’t need any
more Dark Lords”. George writes morally complex
conflicts. Where’s the moral challenge here?
With the wildlings, Jon realised his enemies
aren’t evil, so instead he made peace with them.
Is it possible that Jon could also make peace with
the white walkers? Jon wants to learn about the
white walkers, wants to communicate with them.
And in the books, the white walkers can talk, they
have their own language, they make things out of
ice. George calls them “beautiful”, “elegant”, “a
different sort of life” – maybe the white walkers
have a right to exist. In Book 5, Patrek jokes
that Jon will offer the white walkers hospitality,
will welcome them as guests. So maybe Jon will.
There are theories that Jon won’t destroy the
white walkers – that he’ll make a peace deal.
It is possible to make agreements with the white
walkers – like, Craster gives babies to the white
walkers, and so they don’t attack him. And there’s
the legend of the Night’s King. The Night’s King
was a Commander of the Night’s Watch who married
a cold woman with blue eyes, and made sacrifices
to the white walkers. So there are theories that
the previous Long Night ended not with a battle,
but with a marriage pact, where the Night’s King
married a wight, and the Watch agreed to give them
babies. There are theories that the Starks are
descended from the Night’s King and his queen. And
that Jon is owed or promised to the white walkers,
that they want him to become a new Night’s King.
Maybe while Jon is dead, the white walkers will
take over Jon’s body – just like they raised
those wights in Book 1. Jon does have a dream
where he’s armoured in ice – maybe his body will
be influenced or marked by the white walkers.
The Night’s King fell in love with a pale
woman with blue eyes. So maybe the walkers
will tempt Jon with a pale blue-eyed woman –
like the wildling Val. In Book 5, Val wears
a striking white outfit, with her blue eyes and a
weirwood pin – if she dies, maybe she could become
a zombie seductress to Jon. Jon might get visions
from the white walkers telling him to marry her,
that this is the only way to end the Long Night.
Jon could become Lord Snow of the Nightfort – and
by giving Val his magic seed, and sacrificing a
few babies, he could make peace between the white
walkers and humanity. This could be tempting. But
marrying a zombie and sacrificing babies to demons
is maybe not a good peace agreement – it’s a moral
corruption, a deal with the devil. The Night’s
King and Craster’s deals didn’t permanently
stop the white walkers. Whatever temptation the
white walkers offer, Jon should refuse them.
Cause the white walkers may not be evil Dark
Lords. But they’re also not misunderstood moral
people. They seem more like a destructive force
of nature, an imbalance in the seasons. They are
a contrast to humanity, and a reason for humanity
to unite. Unlike the petty destructive wars of
lords, the war against the walkers really is
worth fighting, for the survival of life itself.
George Martin writes about the evil of war,
but he says some wars are necessary, like stopping
the Nazis in World War Two. So Jon should not make
a deal with the white walkers. It’s prophesied
that the hero must fight this darkness.
The prophecy says that Azor Ahai, or the prince
that was promised, will be reborn to lead the
fight against the darkness. When Melisandre
looks in her flames for a glimpse of Azor Ahai,
she sees Jon “Snow”. As a Stark and a Targaryen,
Jon is of ice and fire, and Rhaegar says of the
hero that “his is the song of ice and fire”.
Jon is literally a prince who was “promised”,
when Ned promised Lyanna. It’s prophesied
that Azor Ahai will be descended from Aerys,
and Jon is Aerys’ grandson. It’s prophesied that
Azor Ahai will wake dragons from stone, and Jon
will wake his dragon identity in the stone crypts.
It’s prophesied that Azor Ahai will be reborn
beneath a bleeding star amidst smoke and salt.
And there are bloody stars and smoke and salty
tears when Jon is killed. It’s said Azor Ahai
will wield a flaming sword called Lightbringer.
This could be a metaphor for dragons. But it could
also be a literal flaming sword. Undead Beric can
light a sword on fire with his blood. So maybe
undead Jon will light his sword on fire with his
blood. It might be that the Dayne sword Dawn is
the true Lightbringer, so maybe Jon will get Dawn
and light it on fire to make it Lightbringer. It
all fits – Jon could be Azor Ahai reborn. Daenerys
also fits the prophecy, so Jon and Dany could
both play a role. The original Azor Ahai forged
Lightbringer by sacrificing his beloved wife.
In the TV show, Arya destroys the white walkers
by killing their leader, the Night King. In
the books so far, there is no Night King. But
Melisandre says the white walkers are controlled
by the Great Other, the god of ice and darkness,
“whose name may not be spoken”. This nameless
white walker god sounds like the old gods,
the gods of the weirwood trees, who are also
described as “nameless”. In the show, and probably
also in the books, the white walkers were created
by the children of the forest with the magic of
the old gods. And the white walkers are often
associated with trees. So maybe the Great Other
is some kinda evil offshoot of the old gods. In
the TV show, we see a frozen weirwood tree, where
the white walkers were created. In the books,
Bran sees “the heart of winter”, which seems to
be the centre of white walker power in the far
far north. So maybe the Great Other is here,
at the heart of winter, an evil spirit in a frozen
tree, controlling the white walkers. And to defeat
them, Jon has to destroy this tree. YouTuber
David Lightbringer has videos on this theory.
He points out that in the TV show, Beric stabs a
spiral of corpses with his flaming sword, which
could represent burning the spiral frozen tree.
This could be Jon’s destiny – to destroy the
Great Other, he must journey north. George
Martin said that in the final books we’ll
see further north than ever before. The journey
could be similar to the legend of the last hero.
The last hero “set out into the dead lands” with
a “dragonsteel” sword and a dog and his friends,
and got the help of the children of the forest to
defeat the white walkers. Maybe Jon will journey
north with his sword and his dog, guided by Bran’s
magic. He could assemble an all-star team of
badass rangers to join him, fighting the dead,
dying one by one. For the final stretch north,
beyond “the curtain of light at the end of the
world”, Jon and Daenerys might fly north on their
dragons. Maybe Jon will convince Daenerys that
the war against the walkers is more important than
her war for the Iron Throne – that their duty
to the realm matters more than their desires.
So Jon and Daenerys will face the heart of winter.
And to destroy the white walkers, they’ll need to
do more than just burn a tree. Cause the legends
of Azor Ahai, and the themes of Jon’s story
emphasise sacrifice, and tough moral choices.
The original Azor Ahai killed his wife,
as a sacrifice, to make the sword Lightbringer.
So maybe Jon has to kill Daenerys to get her
fire into his sword, to burn the Great Other.
Maybe Dany will willingly offer her life to
save the world. Will Jon kill his lover?
Jon has made sacrifices. He sacrificed
Ygritte to protect the realm. He took
Gilly’s baby to save another. He risked
the Night’s Watch to save Arya. This could
be Jon’s ultimate choice between duty and
love – will he kill Daenerys to save the world?
Bloodraven and Melisandre might tell Jon it’s
worth sacrificing one person for the world.
That Jon must take this fiery power and rule
as the last dragonlord. That it’s his destiny,
because of the prophecy and his magic blood.
But this series questions fantasy tropes like
destiny, prophecy and special bloodlines. The
magic Targaryen dynasty was often a disaster –
their flawed personalities, and their dragons,
caused terrible destruction. Special
bloodlines put awful kings on the Throne,
the whole feudal class system is a horrific
injustice. The moral of this story is not that
Jon deserves power because of his Targaryen blood.
And prophecy often backfires – like at Summerhall,
and with Rhaegar, and Stannis – “Prophecy
will bite your prick off every time”.
So Jon should not blindly follow prophecy.
Especially not the prophecy of Azor Ahai – that
dude killed his wife to get a sword. Is he really
a hero? There’s a suspiciously similar legend
about the evil Bloodstone Emperor, who killed
the Amethyst Empress to steal her power. The
legendary Grey King killed a female dragon and
stole fire power. The Winged Knight married a
child of the forest, who then died in childbirth,
and he rode a dragon. All these legends are of a
man who killed a woman and got magic power –
and half these guys seem like evil tyrants,
not saviours. It might be that the original
Azor Ahai actually caused the Long Night,
not ended it. Killing some magic woman might’ve
been the original sin, the fire stolen from the
gods, that unbalanced the cosmos in the first
place. Whatever the original Azor Ahai did,
it didn’t destroy the white walkers – they
came back. So why should Jon repeat this cycle
of violence by sacrificing Dany? This choice
will define Jon’s morality, and his identity.
Because Jon has the magic blood. He could fulfil
the prophecy, sacrifice Dany, and rule. But what
makes Jon special, what makes him a worthy hero,
is not his blood, or a prophecy. Jon is a hero
because of his choices. Jon learned humility and
compassion at the Watch. He was raised as Ned
Stark’s bastard, and Ned taught him justice, and
mercy – Jon thinks of Ned when he spares Ygritte.
He thinks of Ned when he spares that old man.
Surely when Jon faces Dany at the heart of winter,
he’ll again think of Ned, and will spare Dany.
In Book 1, Ned himself tells Robert to not kill
Daenerys. So now, Jon can do the same, he can
become Ned’s true heir, by sparing Daenerys.
He can reject the temptation of fiery power and
prophecy, just as he rejects the white walkers,
and instead make a human moral choice.
Instead of killing Dany, Jon might sacrifice
himself. Jon has often been willing to
give his life for others. In Book 3,
he thinks if he has to die to save the north,
then that’s what he’ll do. Qhorin taught him that
self-sacrifice is the meaning of the Night’s Watch
oath. So after all Jon’s struggle with his vows,
in the end, he can keep his oath, by giving his
life to destroy the white walkers. Daenerys could
stab Jon to forge Lightbringer. Or he could
stab himself, impale himself on the frozen
tree – giving up his fiery blood to burn the
Great Other. A heroic self-sacrifice could be a
fitting ending to Jon’s story. Like his dream of a
glorious death in Book 1. It’s… almost… too easy.
Here's another possibility – instead of killing
himself or Daenerys, maybe Jon will sacrifice his
dragon Rhaegal. Because Rhaegal represents Jon’s
Targaryen side. Rhaegal gives him the power of
fire and of flight. Rhaegal is named for Jon’s
father, represents his legitimacy as a Targaryen
king. If Jon kills Rhaegal, he gives up that
power. In all the history and lore of this world,
there are no examples of a dragonrider killing
their own dragon. Because of the magic bond,
it would be like killing part of yourself. Killing
Rhaegal would be a profound sacrifice, and it
could finally resolve Jon’s identity crisis.
Jon could reject his destructive Targaryen side,
and instead follow Ned Stark’s moral example –
giving up his own power to save others. Cause
Jon is not defined by his blood. He is not a
Targaryen. He’s not even a Stark. He is Jon Snow,
and he chooses to follow Ned’s moral example.
Jon could stab Rhaegal with his sword,
so the dragon’s fire goes into the blade, creating
Lightbringer. Then he can stab the frozen tree,
burning the Great Other, and destroying the white
walkers. He’ll save the world, not by sacrificing
others and seizing power, like Azor Ahai and
Tywin and Ramsay and all the other monstrous
men in this story. Instead Jon could make a human
moral choice to save others. He’ll end the Long
Night. But there’ll still be one more sad war.
A Song of Ice and Fire is partly George Martin’s
response to The Lord of the Rings, the classic
fantasy story. Jon Snow is like Aragorn – they’re
both warriors and leaders who fight to save
the world. They both have tragic romances,
both are secret heirs to the kingdom. But George
questions Aragorn’s happy ending, where he
marries the girl and rules well for a hundred
years. Jon’s ending will be darker than that.
George loves the bit at the end of the Lord
of the Rings called the Scouring of the Shire.
After the Dark Lord is defeated, the hobbits
go home, and find there’s still evil in the
world – Saruman took over the Shire, and there’s
this sad ugly conflict to remove him. Frodo can’t
live happily ever after, cause he’s wounded
and traumatised, so instead he sails west – and
magic fades from the world of men. It’s about
the cost of victory, the impact of violence,
and the inevitability of change. The heroes save
the world, but at great cost. The ending is happy,
but also sad – it’s bittersweet. George says the
end of A Song of Ice and Fire will be similar.
So Jon might also face a sad final conflict.
Maybe he’ll come to King’s Landing so Daenerys
can rule, but they’ll find Cersei on the throne –
vindictively clinging to power, holding the city’s
civilians hostage. Like in TV show, Daenerys will
probably burn King’s Landing, killing thousands
of innocent people. In the TV show, she does
this deliberately, out of anger and madness,
but in the books it might be accidental, because
of the wildfire. Cersei, Tyrion or JonCon might
also be involved. Maybe Daenerys will lose control
of her dragon, and Drogon will burn the city
against her will. Daenerys struggles to control
Drogon in the books. In Hot D, Viserys says
dragons cannot be controlled, they are inherently
destructive. Like the icy white walkers, dragon
fire is an apocalyptic threat to this world.
So like in the TV show, Daenerys will win the
Throne, but will be hated by the people
and the lords. Visions hint that Young
Griff will be popular. So after Daenerys burns
him and burns King’s Landing, no one will want
Dany to be queen. And they’ll want her dragon
dead – like in the storming of the Dragonpit.
So to bring peace to the realm, Jon might have
to bring down Daenerys and kill her dragon.
Daenerys sees her dragons as her children. They
are her power, and her identity as a Targaryen
dragon queen. After everything she’s lost, if
her last dragon dies, she’ll have nothing. If
Jon kills Drogon, she’d see that as the ultimate
betrayal – that could be the prophesied third
treason. But Jon may see that the realm can’t have
peace while a dangerous dragon lives and while
Daenerys has the throne. This will be another
painful moral dilemma for Jon – will he betray
his love to protect the realm? Make another
tragic sacrifice, to save the world from fire,
just as he saved it from ice? He will want
Daenerys’ love, he will want to rule with her,
but he’ll know that peace is more important than
his desires. It will destroy Jon if he has to kill
Daenerys. Maybe he could fake Daenerys’ death so
she can escape to the east – tragically separating
the lovers? There’s lots of possibilities.
Maybe we’ll make a Real Daenerys video to
explore her fate. But it makes sense that Jon
will bring down Daenerys, and that her dragons
will die. Cause in the books, dragons make magic
stronger in the world. If the last dragon dies,
magic could fade away. Like at the end of The
Lord of the Rings. It’s the end of fantasy,
and the beginning of a world more like our own.
Another possibility is instead of killing Dany,
Jon might have to kill King Bran. Cause Bran
might be a sinister puppet of Bloodraven and
the old gods – having a creepy inhuman tree wizard
as king might be a bad thing. And George Martin’s
original outline of the series said that Jon
and Bran would become enemies. The old gods
seem like a sinister force, manipulating humanity
– so maybe, like the dragons and white walkers,
they need to be destroyed. Jon might have to
reluctantly kill his beloved brother Bran.
Whether he kills King Bran or kills Daenerys,
Jon will know he’ll be exiled for this murder.
So this’ll be another self-sacrifice.
Despite all his heroism, he won’t get
to go home to Winterfell, or be a king. He
won’t get love and glory – he might be hated,
as a traitor and murderer. Jon will give up
everything to save a world that rejects him.
In Book 1, Benjen said Jon didn’t know what he
was giving up by joining the Watch. But now,
Jon has experienced love with Ygritte,
and Dany. He’s experienced power at the
Wall and on dragonback, tasted glory in battle.
He’s no longer a boy, he’s a man, he’s lived,
and now he understands what he’s giving up.
That’s what makes his sacrifice meaningful.
So like in the TV show, Jon may be exiled beyond
the Wall. He’ll be separated from the Starks. He
might get to join the wildlings – Tormund says
he’ll make Jon a true wildling. Ygritte was right,
Jon likes the free folk life. And he had always
felt like an outcast, like the wildlings. Maybe
Jon will finally get to be with Val, if
she’s still alive. With the free folk,
Jon would be free of war, of politics, of vows.
But like Frodo, he’ll be wounded. After his death
and resurrection, and his sacrifices, Jon won’t
be whole. Maybe he’ll be a husk like Coldhands and
Beric, unable to feel or enjoy life. Maybe zombie
Jon will wander to that cave, where Ygritte wanted
to stay. And there he’ll remain, with his memories
of warmth, with his loves and losses, forever.
George Martin loves fantasy – heroes, romance,
and magic – but he sees that the real world is
more complex. So his characters grow up, they
are disillusioned, they learn that the world
is not a fairy tale. Good and evil are not
black and white, we can’t rely on prophesied
princes to save the world. So in a complex
real world, what does it mean to be a hero?
Jon Snow is a deconstruction of the classic
fantasy hero. Cause he is a secret prince, heir
to the kingdom, prophesied to save the world – but
will reject destiny, reject his birthright, reject
the fantasy tropes. His heroism is realer and more
human. Cause Jon struggles to do the right thing,
he makes morally grey choices. He has doubts,
temptation, conflicted desires, but he persists,
he chooses to save others. That’s what makes
him heroic. It’s not cause of prophecy or magic,
but because people’s lives matter. In a complex
cynical real world, that’s the heroism we need.
At the end of this series, there’ll still be
evil in the world, there’ll still be darkness
and weakness in every heart. But Jon
embodies the eternal human struggle
for light in a dark world – a dream of spring.
Thanks for watching. We’re making more videos
about A Song of Ice and Fire, and House of the
Dragon, and Dune, so press like and subscribe.
We’ve already made videos about Bloodraven,
Rhaegar, ancient Stark mysteries, Grand Northern
Conspiracy, and more so check those out. Thank
you to Bella Bergolts, Ertaç Altınöz and Sanrixian
for making illustrations for this video. Shoutout
to the Song of Ice and Fire experts linked below
whose excellent analysis helped inform this
video. And thank you to the Patrons – support
Alt Shift X on Patreon to get extra updates and
monthly livestreams. Thanks to Patrons Stanislav
Kolontaev, jackjmoore, Andrew, Arran Shackell,
Rosemary Walsh, Ben Warner, and Aurora. Cheers.